michel la cassette de son spectacle
pas de l'année 1999 et début 2000
faisait passer le réveillon là bas alors
votre nouveau spectacle donc ça commence
le 10 octobre jusqu'au 12 novembre au
casino de paris mise en scène d'alain
sachs donc et puis ensuite après vous
partez en tournée le 18 novembre jusqu'à
fin avril 2001 alors bon vous allez en
france évidemment en suisse en belgique
jusque là je comprends maroc au canada
et aux usa comment vous faites aux usa
bat aux usa il ya une partie du
spectacle qui traduit traduite en
anglais
ouais et c'est vous qui parlez anglais
moi je parle anglais en partie et tout
le reste est très visuel tout ce qui est
visuel dans ce spectacle de ce faire don
aux états unis et il ya une partie aussi
du spectacle qui est jazz et où il ya un
hommage à tous les chanteurs de jazz
américaine en parler et donc à ce moment
là je fais un espèce de mélange tout ça
pendant une heure une heure et demie
voilà alors les auteurs - iliad abadie
avec qui vous avez fait un sketch sur
les restos à la mode jean yanne molière
évidemment voilà c'est ça bien il ya de
la noue et alors ça c'est incroyable
parce qu'il a quel âge pierre delanoë il
a carrément mis sa jeune gars qui a
maintenant 80 et quelques années et qui
a écrit une chanson qui s'appelle il ya
une boum dans le bar-tabac d'en bas
ça ce n'est pas sympa fait c'est
interactif avec le public c'est à dire
que au départ tout comme tout le monde
pense que ce serait très facile et ça se
complique évidemment parce qu'on rajoute
un mot à chaque fois et c'est l'intérêt
de la chose alors il ya deux sketches en
référence à la blague qui est l'essence
même de ce métier
vous savez que nous ici on fait le
championnat de france de blague c'est à
dire que les gens nous envoient les
cassettes on a commencé à en recevoir
il se filme ils sont filmés par leurs
femmes avec leur caméscope ou leurs
voisins avec son dvd
ils nous envoient les camions ou les
cassettes à l'adresse qui est indiqué en
bas de l'écran pendant que je parle et
les meilleurs sont diffusés les
meilleurs des meilleurs viendront les
raconter en plateau alors votre femme
dit que vous êtes anxieux et que 48
heures avant une première vous dormez
pas vous voulez vous vous décontracter
un peu la malaisie
je suis liquéfiée alors il va y avoir
des critiques le lendemain matin
évidemment vous êtes touché par les
critiques
bah oui évidemment un point quand elles
sont mauvaises elles nous font mal quand
elles sont bonnes elles le font demain
c'est tellement énorme aussi penser que
les critiques vous aident à progresser
et c'est non non c'est en général une
critique c'est extrêmement c'est
physique comment l'accès devant une
critique où on saute de joie où on est
effondré moi c'est sa chance sachant
pertinemment que d'une manière générale
les critiques n'ont pratiquement aucune
influence sur le succès d'un cias à
l'échec d'un smic vous ça vous touche
quand même moi ça me touche d'ailleurs
est alors fait vachement plaisir
si je dis que ça me touche ouais vous
été très critiqué d'une façon générale
au delà la critique qu'on lira le
lendemain du casino de paris
en fait elle était catalogué à vos
débuts comme un comme un comique
grimacier ça vient sans doute de votre
célèbres imitations de jerry lewis la
main lorsque fameux sketch de la machine
à écrire puis aussi les vous faisiez les
noirs les chinois dont il ya plein de
belles belles âmes qui vous ont vu
qu'ils me l'ont reproché en vous
traitant de raciste moi je trouve que
maintenant le débat complètement dépassé
probablement que ça a été pris au
premier degré par par la critique au
départ c'est 7 est regrettable parce
qu'il était évident qu'il n'y avait pas
l'ombre d'un l'ombre d'un d'une forme de
racisme dans aucun de mes propos et j'en
veux pour preuve très souvent
l'intervention de d'amis africains ou de
noir avec lesquels j'ai pu travailler ou
même des spectacles que j'ai pu donner
en afrique où les africains eux-mêmes
venait me trouver pour me donner des
répliques exactes et dégâts qu'il
fallait dire et les mots précis qu'il
fallait utiliser dans les sketchs sinon
ce n'était pas bon et mutations à cas
donc je dis aux paras franchement si
vraiment il y avait eu un problème je
pense que je leur ai senti de la part
des intéressés et je crois qu'en général
les gens qui voient une forme de racisme
quelconque dans ce que j'aurais pu faire
une époque c'est que eux mêmes avaient
sûrement un problème alors en 95 et fait
un spectacle pour les 50 ans de l'onu
voilà justement il y avait des noirs des
jaunes les blancs des rouges et les 147
dignitaires de 47 pays c'était à l'onu
d'ailleurs new york et vous avez imiter
des noirs dans ce spectacle ah oui à la
demande des noirs d'ailleurs oui
donc je vais pas trop vite non vous avez
dit j'aimerais bien être noir
mais d'une façon générale comme ça on
dit moi j'aime bien les noirs parce
qu'ils ont le sens du rythme où c'est
plus profond que ça non c'est parce que
en fait je trouve que les noirs qu'en
fait ce que je connais en afrique quand
on y va
et cette sorte de naïveté de gentillesse
tout à fait naturel chez eux je leur
prends une chose c'est cesser de parler
exactement comme moi donc de piquer tous
mes plans mais sinon d'une manière
générale ils sont ils sont
formidablement gentier agréable bon et
en dehors de ça bon en dehors comme vous
le dites le sens du rythme la
publication le goût du jazz etc
ça c'est vrai que les noirs sont
absolument imbattable alors vous été
influencé par jerry lewis on l'a dit et
puis vous êtes allé le voir alors vous
c'est incroyable parce que c'est le 23
avril 72 donc c'est jour de votre
anniversaire en plus vous débrouillez
vous allez voir le show de jerry lewis
tous les soirs je me fait passer pour un
journaliste belge d'abord ray vous avez
fait l'accent belge alors naturellement
j'ai décalé je m'appelle gerard poireau
j'aime bien ici pour l'interview et le
mec m'a dit rentre et même pas demandé
mes papiers rien ce dessert est donc un
soir vous arrivez à vous infiltrer dans
sa loge et vous le supplier de venir
voir un court métrage qui s'appelait à
tout hasard que vous aviez tourné
il est venu le voir est venu le voir
l'effective ans je trouvais ça bien et
les trouve ça pas mal c'était difficile
dont il était très bien élevé à très
bien élevés djaoui très gentil il m'a
donné deux trois conseils techniques et
grâce à ça j'ai continué à tourner
quelques courts métrages par la suite
pour le plaisir et puis voilà et après
il est venu me voir dans une boîte où je
passais à paris et alors ça c'est le 23
avril 72 et le 23 avril toujours votre
anniversaire le 23 avril 89
vous rencontrez sinatra c'est quand même
pour vous effectivement l'idole absolue
elle est formidable et là on découvre un
petit peu au-delà de du comique au delà
on découvre l'autre michel leeb c'est à
dire le jazzman manning gigas
si le cinéma
un peu
m
prot
california
et on le laisse faire
ouais bravo à ces jeunes michel leeb qui
est peut-être un peu moins connus bouaké
et alors est ce que vous êtes un vrai
chanteur à la sinatra ce qu'on vient de
voir là où est-ce que vous imiter un
vrai chanteur ça qu'on sait pas plus
et oui j'essaye d'éviter un bon chanteur
soit effectivement sinatra c'est pas
exactement ça et mais en réalité
j'aime tellement ça bien sûr le le fait
de chanter avec un big band basie
orchestra c'est génial quand bézis tél
et bien c'est un sentiment
extraordinaire ce qu'on ait porté comme
dans la 747 à dix mille pieds je vais
très chaud ici et c'est très très bien
ici c'est un grand bonheur mais c'est
vraiment il faut bien dire une chose
c'est que tout ce que je fais là c'est
vraiment uniquement pour le pied oui ce
qu'on appelle le pied ça j'en fais sur
une qualité qu'on fait pour le voile
alors ça c'était un août michel viala
encore assez le comédien qui a joué
douze hommes en colère allemagne avec un
certain succès pendant combien de temps
ça marche il était en tournée avec et
deux ans et demi à deux ans et demi
c'est énorme
et puis encore un autre michel est donc
vous voyez là plein dé michel et
cohabitent bien est vous êtes bien
ensemble sous les 6 c'est le prof de
philo c'est à dire que vous avez été
prof de philo j'ai une maîtrise de philo
ce des profs de philo ça fait un moment
et vous êtes fait virer parce que vous y
mettiez quand vous faisiez des cours ça
va être génial d'ailleurs vous limitiez
les philosophes allemands wypelier
comment par exemple et des guerres et
des guerres là il se passait quelque
chose d'assez s'il était viré il faut le
dire quand même pas forcément on peut
pas avancer les médias mais pas que ça
vous alliez souvent boire des coups au
bistrot avec les étudiantes
si elle veut donner des cours
particuliers voilà chacun a compris et
évidemment un moment donné ça mais en
tous les cas cette expérience de
professorat a réveillé chez vous le
comédien parce que vous avez commencé
très tôt en fait à 4 ans vous y mettiez
mussolini ce que vous dire votre mère
était italienne donc à 4 ans vous
invitiez mussolini le menton comme ça
lâche que quand elles vont oublier ça et
à 10 ans vous allez voir molière à la
comédie française va vous a été baigné
là dedans un débris plus jeune âge et
quand vous avez été prof vous étiez sur
une estrade peut-être pas une scène mais
ça vous a donné envie d' essai une à dix
comédiens
c'est une manière de jouer la comédie
sert d'enseigné bien sûr si chez les
jésuites premier prix de récitation
donc voilà donc c'est vrai que vous
aviez quand même y avait 1 comme on dit
un terrain favorable et vous avez un
choc quand vous étiez petit c'est que
votre père est parti quand vous avez une
dizaine d'années partis en amérique où
la vertu bien plus tard et ça a
développé chez vous une sensualité très
très particulière de sensualité hors du
commun
selon m non mais c'est vrai au plan
morphologique donc je sais c'est son
plan dans son logis bien entendu il
faudra bien le dire tout ça cette
capacité des tirs et ça bouge cette
capacité voilà fait voir oui à voir et
revoir des amis voilà une narine
frémissant rythme là les narines comme
le cheval qui lui à ceux qui s'apprêtent
à galoper comme ça ça très bien ouais
non le regard de velours fait moi le
regarde mais aussi bref alors alors non
mais c'est vrai vous avez développé vous
aviez envie de vous d'exister dans le
regard des autres parce que vous étiez
un peu tout seul chez les chez les jays
est alors j'étais très beau vous avez
été élu mister côte d'azur à ça c'est
génial mais ça c'est extraordinaire
c'est comme en maillot de bain léopard
je choisirais le bio par esi je me suis
pour neda et j'ai été élu mister côte
d'azur au sort déconnant complètement
j'aime beaucoup de succès maintenant
vous êtes un peu rangé des voitures 1
vous dites ans par le régime il était un
peu rangé des voitures là matin vous
êtes marié remarier oui oui on a dit
qu'on ne connaît pas parce que votre
femme est en régie béatrice il faut
noter qu'au passé voilà nos rangs 87
dans sexy folies
le caire bout à chaque fois ils vont
être béatrice cédric et à claques qui
parle de béatrice matis mais je sais pas
si drucker ils disent que je vais dire
en 87 dans sexy folies vous avouer
tromper votre femme en fait celle qui
est devenue votre femme après bien
entendu mais à l'époque vous étiez déjà
avec elle béatrice et vous dit un truc
intéressant vous dit
à cette époque là la fidélité ça se
passe dans la tête ça et on dit
n'importe quoi à vrai dire à ma femme ça
nous est arrivé à la convaincre que la
fidélité ça se passe dans la tête et que
le après on peut avoir des aventures à
droite à gauche
c'est elle qui m'a convaincu de seurre
départ ouais c'est du pur à wemmel et
formé à raison de l'est plus
ou alors vous êtes mariés donc voilà il
ya prescription 91 vous marier à las
vegas ça c'est votre premier mariage au
deuxième jour là cet été pour de vrai la
société vous avez fait le curé tout non
1 cet été quand vous être marié avec
votre femme vous avez fait le curé moi
j'ai pas fait que les préfectures et je
me suis marié à oppède ouais mais ça
avec la mer un civil quoi pas de 1
arrivé à kiev un curé dans une chapelle
d'accorder votre fameuse chapelle que
vous avez restauré la voilà d'accord
votre âge vous le dit non mais combien
c'est bien il est honnête vous - dit pas
non vous avez dit en face terrible ça
faire flipper tout le monde ça va casser
l'ambiance vous allez dis ce 1er janvier
2000 en parlant ni pour les gens les
2000 on va tous se réveiller dans un
siècle qui est celui où on va mourir
c'est dur c'est vrai tous ici je vous le
dis à tous
on va tous mourir dans siècle c'est vrai
dieu qu'est la jolie fille complètement
à l'arrêt c'est vrai il ya très peu de
rigueur là et alors françoise a remis
pour le zarbi m'avait dit un truc comme
ça qui met bien fait flipper pendant
longtemps je le dis si des fois vous
êtes alors elle avait dit un truc
terrible pour ce dernier l'avait dit mon
cher thierry on a plus que 20 fois à
voir fleurir les roses syrien vers fois
rien c'est fou ce que ça peut en
profiter
icesave alors
non
je vous demande de vous arrêter je vous
demande de vous arrêter